mans frédéric jeanjean depuis marseille
est également avec nous je le rappelle
vous êtes secrétaire général de l'union
des métiers et des industries de
l'hôtellerie
le gouvernement parle d'une embellie 1 à
marseille olivier véran va s'entretenir
demain avec les élus locaux
l'ouverture des cafés restaurants sans
doute au menu je vous propose d'écouter
olivier ferrand vous réagissez ensuite
frédéric jeanjean
le gouvernement va dans les prochains
jours examiner les propositions qui lui
sont faites c'est normal par les
représentants du secteur de la
restauration et étudier des règles
éventuels qui pourraient permettre aux
restaurants y compris en zone d' alerte
maximale de rester en tout ou partie
ouvert mais avec des règles sanitaires
renforcés pour permettre de limiter au
maximum les risques de contamination ces
nouvelles règles si elle nous semble si
elle nous semble suffisamment robustes
protectrice contrôlable seront alors
soumises au haut conseil de santé
publique elle si elle était validée elle
pourrait alors s'appliquer dans tous les
territoires en zone d' alerte maximale
alors frédéric jeanjean caisse quand
vous réagissez à ses propos d'olivier
ferrand est ce que vous espérez un
changement de traitement dès demain tout
d'abord gérer quel gâchis quel gâchis
comme monsieur vers ans est descendu à
marseille la semaine dernière leur
demande à leur encontre et justement
pour lui proposer ces mesures il a fallu
une semaine de mobilisation
il a fallu pousser toute une filière les
cafetiers les restaurateurs et les
fournisseurs à bout pour qu en fait il
se décide à écouter ce que nous pouvons
proposer
je trouve ça assez fort de café
parce que nous arrivons nous avons des
propositions faire nous connaissons nos
métiers et nous savons ce que nous
pouvons avancer
et là tout d'un coup effectivement
monsieur venir parler de la pentecôte
mais je dirais mais c'est même mieux que
ça
les sourds entendent et les aveugles se
met à voir alors figurez-vous que venant
à marseille fait demain à marseille nous
une grande manifestation est bien
monsieur vers ans a trouvé opportun de
nous consulter de mer en fin de matinée
parce que il s'est rendu compte que
outre les statistiques
outre une situation que nous connaissons
tous
parce que les professionnels que nous
sommes nous entendons nous voyons dans
nos proches nos familles nos clients
chez nos salariés que cette maladie pose
un problème
nous ne sommes pas inconscient nous
voulons trouver des solutions parce
qu'il faut quand même que nous puissions
vivre malgré ce virus trouver des
solutions et j'irai même plus loin
comment se fait-il que alors qu'on est
confronté cette pandémie
on voit dans les transports en commun
les choses absolument effarante et qu'on
voit ça dans toutes les métropoles et
que derrière ça dans les centres
commerciaux dans les grandes surfaces on
voit les choses tout aussi aberrante
eh bien nous les cafetiers et les
restaurateurs
nous nous refusons et surtout le pays
maintenant à servir de variable
d'ajustement pour la communication d'un
gouvernement qui ne sait pas où il va
alors s'il veut trouver une direction
qu'il se tourne vers les locaux qui se
tournent vers les acteurs de terrain
vers les représentants des métiers que
nous que nous sommes nous ne pouvons
avancer des propositions des solutions
nous ne sommes pas des scientifiques
c'est pas nous qui diront si elles sont
bonnes ou mauvaises
mais nous avons l'exemple de l'italie à
côté de chez nous où se rend compte que
l'épidémie fait moins de ravages
parce qu'ils ont vidés protocole
renforcé alors pourquoi est-ce qu'on a
perdu tout ce temps là pourquoi est ce
que nous nous avons perdu une semaine ou
n'ont pas pu travailler ou n'ont pas pu
créer de la richesse et cette richesse
est le sert justement à bombay sur
l'ensemble du territoire pour aider les
soignants pour aider les gens qui sont
malades pour aider les gens qui sont en
difficulté c'est ce gâchis qui nous rend
pauvre de nous